new little ooh whatta baby boo boo oh
[ __ ] hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to old [ __ ] oh I
don't I don't know
oh god well they spit up on the blood of
their fro [ __ ] [ __ ] I have no idea
what I'm doing
oh I got one guy left Oh God okay well I
guess it's much easier when I just got
one guy going okay so welcome to this
game oh look at his little butt go run
little guy Ron do with your stump arms
and your stump legs woah
I guess I earned a friend okay yeah yeah
yeah oh [ __ ] Roger [ __ ] gonna do what
did I do
oh [ __ ] alright here we go again I guess
so I don't know a lot about this game
but it's quick game that I found on it
geo and it featured some adorable are
working on see alive stay fit and stay
alive oh god run oh no that guy in the
back needs to pick it up up up
Oh only some of them can jump oh god I
can't see there's so much blood oh god
that guy can jump okay
this is safe to stay on each other's
heads you'll be totally fine you guys
got this you guys got this oh you guys
don't got this do you you're about to
fall off time to jump when you're on my
head brah actually could you get off my
head there we go okay so each of them
have individual characteristics and I'm
certain that's randomly generated but
only this guy can jump so I got to keep
track of him huh make it over okay you
made it over huh make it over okay oh
yeah okay okay alright oh there's so
much blood oh god there's body parts
okay so I don't know a lot about this
game and I don't know a lot about what
it means if it's some dystopian society
where you have to do on this game show
or die horribly maybe this is the
Soylent Green Factory oh geez I feel so
bad if he says Lucas they're so cute and
adorable and this is a horrible and non
stop and I think I'm gonna go for a
record here apparently so this game is
completely randomly generated I suspect
any whoa
that guy's got mad hops where
well well so it doesn't do oh [ __ ] no
[ __ ] dude you got everyone killed why
did the guy that could jump the best be
in the back you couldn't hurt all over
it huh man these chubby little dudes
need to go for it the like little sack
boys they're like little fat sack boys
oh man
oh god that guy in the back he looks so
cool right before he's about to die and
I gotta admit this game has got some
good art style to it like unified at
least oh no oh god no well at least
there's no blood
that's what I can appreciate well that
guy's dead I guess if they get crushed
under there there's no place for the
blood I don't know what kind of facility
is built like this is a long hallway of
death oh well not gonna question it
there's gonna just gonna live it okay so
this guy this guy in the backs he's my
champ like I said Oh God well there's
the blood I guess some of them have
blood and some of them do not do not get
in my way you ass
you got my way you ass okay you better
be able to jump because I don't have any
patience for the skin oh [ __ ] you've got
the worst hops dude you've got the
miniscule hops if that guy's got no
better hops at least he's doing he's got
a little bit better hops oh the other
guy ran out of hops so you can only jump
so many times even with the guys that
can jump alright there's a bit of a
strategy to this one there's a bit of a
strategy okay alright I got it
[ __ ] no god damn and you got bounced
back God you guys betray each other they
would be able to survive if they just
work together alright one more go one
more go on this alright let's do this
come on don't [ __ ] around with me this
is death we're talking about here it
comes hard and fast you don't want to be
swoo we got a speedy bunch here holy
[ __ ] oh my god there's one superfast guy
whoa
that's immaterial oh my god oh my god
okay oh okay apparently this is Oh what
happened oh god I think my speedy guy no
no we're still here we're good we're
good we're speedy we're good it's just a
lot of death happened that a lot of
blood exploded everywhere but this time
I'm gonna go for a record and we're
gonna get very far in this one I've got
a feel
yeah god damn it you [ __ ] [ __ ] oh
those poor bastards there's poor fastest
they're all dead oh well anyway this is
a short little game there's not much
more to it there's no story apparently I
would like to know a story about this
why the hell are they in this horrible
game show why is there a point can you
win I don't know but either way that is
run chubby dudes run it's a fun little
game so I think my record was like a
minute and 40 something seconds maybe 46
I have no idea but if you guys want to
waste a little bit of time and torture
some adorable creatures then I'll put a
link to the game in the description
below so thank you everybody so much for
watching and thank you developer for
making this sadistic game and as always
I will see you in the next video
[Music]